Where are you from originally?
Kentucky.
And how is your mother enjoying your success?
Oh, she's very happy.
She has more fun than I do.
She called me one time.
Recently I've just gotten into the Academy which was really exciting for me.
That's exciting for any actor.
And then, I got a call from my mother while I was in England...
...and she goes, "I did something hilarious!"
And I was like, "What?"
She was like, "I voted!"
And I was like, "You voted for what?"
"The Oscars!"
And I was like, "You voted for the Oscars?"
"What do you mean?"
She was like, "The ballot came here, and I voted."
Because she thought I'd be like,  "Ah! Ha ha ha."
"That's hilarious, I'm gonna get kicked out of the Academy."
Fortunately, she did it wrong and I think she mailed it back to herself.
So, I got to do it again.
That's horrible.
So, she just thought anybody who receives the ballot can vote?
Like it's the people's choice award or something.
Exactly.
I'm one of the people.
You have to be in the Academy.
Wow, so did you see who she voted?
Did you agree with whom she voted for?
No.
Okay.
No, I didn't.